kiev has been striking back in the
southern herison region now occupied by
russia
ukraine says that its forces destroyed a
russian ammunition depot and killed more
than 50 soldiers russian state media
gave a different account claiming at
least seven people were killed
ukraine is hailing it as a victory as it
tries to drive back russian forces
[Music]
the ukrainian government says this is
the moment its rockets hit a russian
military depot in nova kakova in
ukraine's south
russian-backed officials say u.s
supplied weapons were involved in the
strikes
ukraine's president says his forces are
aiming to reclaim territory
have already felt very well what modern
artillery is and they will not have a
safe rear anywhere on our land which
they occupied
russian forces now occupy large swathes
of ukraine's east
in the city of sivera donetsk they
patrol a landscape turned to rubble
after their assault
similar scenes across the river illicit
chansk where buildings lie in ruins
ukraine's forces retreated in the face
of relentless attack
now russian troops hand out aid to
residents they claim to have liberated
ukraine's flag still flies in bachmut
one of the few remaining cities under
kiev's control in the region of donetsk
as the front line moves closer residents
are preparing for a future which
resembles the past
i remember the war of 1941 i was little
back then now here it's also horror
officials say a third of the population
has already fled and more are following
them but time is running short
drivers say they face a perilous journey
as bombings intensify
across the region
and for more let's cross over to dw's
nick connolly who has the view from kiev
nick as we've been hearing ukrainian
forces hitting back harder against the
russian-backed troops in the south
is this the counter-offensive that
kiev's been telling civilians that it's
preparing for
i think definitely the preparation to
the counter-offensive we've seen ukraine
using new american delivered weapons
rocket artillery systems highmars is the
name to attack
russian logistics hubs russian weapons
depots to basically deprive russia of
that huge advantage it's been having and
taking advantage of in recent weeks and
months of just having seven to ten times
more artillery systems their disposal at
least that's those the figures that the
ukrainians have been uh talking of so
basically they're trying to starve the
russian positions in gerson region which
are already a lot less well equipped
than the russian positions in the east
of the country ahead of them trying to
make some ground and push forward and
really
you know start making progress and
taking more territory for the first time
in in a couple of months and as that
fighting continues nick the united
nations has released new numbers on the
human toll of the war and i'd just like
to um to walk us through some of them
they say that more than 5 million people
have been displaced at least 5 000
civilians killed saying that that number
is actually likely much higher
walk us through how people in ukraine
are coping nearly half a year now into
this war
it is amazing how this country has
continued functioning how the trains
kept running how mobile for phone
connections have been restored after
infrastructure has been destroyed time
and time again no no issue with
electricity for now basic services
available here in kiev certainly but
also places pretty close to the front
lines obviously in donbass closest to
where those artillery battles have been
going on some people have been left
without power without
internet for weeks now but overall the
country is
managing to stand up a lot better than
anyone had it managed but it is now
obviously
after so many months of fighting taking
its toll and there is the question is
how long can individual families
individual uh ukrainians carry on often
without jobs often living off their
savings how long can the government here
carry on paying pensions and wages
there's definitely a big question mark
over western promises of aid we've had
lots of discussion about western weapons
deliveries coming too late and in you
know smaller numbers than promised but
the same is now the case with financial
donations the finance minister here in
kiev worried that lots of the promises
made in the early weeks of the war when
there was all that attention for ukraine
have not materialized yet and there is a
real worry that as this drags on and
attention gets taken to other conflicts
to other uh issues the the cost of
living crisis in europe that ukraine
might end up having to really struggle
to keep the country afloat and to keep
the government machine working and
there's also a lot of worry around the
world um not least because of the more
than 20 million tons of grain
stuck in the country because of the
fighting
nick we understand that delegations from
ukraine and russia are set to meet in
turkey today to discuss a deal to resume
exports more can you tell us on that
front
i think there's not a huge deal of
optimism here in kiev that they'll get
some kind of agreement the basic problem
is that kiev does not trust any promises
from russia so basically you know any
kind of potential deal to take mines sea
mines away to remove them to allow those
ukrainian main ukrainian ports of odessa
and mikolav to reopen that is all pretty
tentative and not looking very likely
for now also the question about whether
commercial shipping uh companies would
actually send their uh private vessels
into you know disputed waters as you
know is the case around odessa but there
is a small piece of hope hopeful news
from the south of ukraine the far south
uh in the danube delta where we've heard
that a new channel has been opened that
allows uh smaller ships to enter
ukrainian ports not the big ports which
used to export most of the grain but
that's basically the first time now
since the beginning of the war that
grain has been exported by sea from
ukraine rather than being shipped across
the borders by land so a small bit of
hope but still a huge problem and new
harvest coming in and no one really with
an answer to where to put all this grain
on top of last year's harvest that's
still there in the silos waiting to be
exported waiting to you know reach
people across the world who are really
struggling with exploding prices for
their bread nick connolly in the
ukrainian capital kiev for us thank you
so much
and here are some other developments
related to the war in ukraine a russian
opposition figure is facing up to 15
years in prison after being charged
under a new law in russia that makes it
a crime to spread false information
about the military ilya yashin has been
a critic of russia's war in ukraine
the russian-backed donest people's
republic has opened an embassy in
central moscow according to the
separatists a solemn opening ceremony
was cancelled due to intensified
shelling in the breakaway region in
eastern ukraine russian foreign minister
sergey lavrov has been expected to take
part in the event
some ukrainians are joining the war
effort in original ways around the
capital kiev a group of hairdressers and
beauticians are offering their skills to
people who survived the russian
occupation
their aim to bring back a little pride
and dignity to those who have lost homes
or loved ones or even survived
torture or rape
dw's nick spicer met up with the
so-called beauty volunteers during their
recent stop in bucha the town now
synonymous with the horrors of war
they have survived the very worst now
these bucha residents want to look their
very best with free haircuts manicures
facials and massages because the beauty
volunteers have come to town
the group's founder olha baliska says
they help those who've suffered because
of the russian invasion
they are still without homes
their houses are damaged
uh
but they want uh to steal um pretty
beautiful but they don't have money for
this they don't have money for
themselves because they need to
maybe rebuild their life again
stylist dennis decanenco had to flee the
war in the east himself he says he's
just doing what he knows best
right now i can do this and i do do what
i do you know
and make some people happy
barbara goleba temenenko says the
volunteers are kind of battalion
fighting in what he calls the beauty
front but their work is often anything
but skin deep to speak with them
to understand understand their
mood
and feelings
to try to understand feelings
and it's like art
therapy i think
and some of the people here say the
treatments give them more than inner
peace they can spark hope
it helps me see butcher in better future
it was a wonderful city a beautiful
european country
we cannot be slaves
we want to be free to live in dignity to
earn money to raise children to rebuild
our town
we will have better times
the beauty volunteers group have been
making trips for around two months now
they only go to places that were invaded
and occupied by russian troops and they
include some of the very best hair
stylists and beauticians in the
ukrainian capital
but founder olha says the volunteers
have to be strong they hear many many
painful stories
but we have
no
maybe choice to be
to cry or to show our feelings no no we
are here to help
that's why we must be strong
we must be
happy smile
the beauty volunteers are hoping to
expand raise more money visit more towns
and cities and as the war grinds on
there's every chance they'll be able to
continue work which they call the way of
serving their country
you